Jake:今天是谷雨
Jake: Today is Grain Rain.
Shure:  今天还是个节气呢
Shure: Today is a solar term.
Jake:对那
Jake: Yeah, that...
Shure:  是个节气吃什么
Shure: What do we eat for this festival?
Shure:  吃饺子吧
Shure: Let's eat dumplings.
Lucia: 遇事不决吃饺子
Lucia: When in doubt, eat dumplings.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  对啊反正咱也不知道吃什么
Shure: Yeah, we don't know what else to eat anyway.
Jake:摘谷雨茶走
Jake: Let's pick some Gu Yu tea and go.
Jake:谷雨祭海
Jake: Gu Yu sea sacrifice.
Jake:吃春赏花
Jake: Eat in spring and enjoy flowers.
Jake:什么玩意
Jake: What the heck.
Lucia: 不知道在赏花
Lucia: No idea, just enjoying flowers.
Lucia: 咱可以有
Lucia: We can have some.
Shure:  那就吃饺子吧
Shure: Then let's eat dumplings.
Jake:吃饺子行
Jake: Dumplings are fine.
Jake:可以啊中午吃饺子吧
Jake: Sure, let's have dumplings for lunch.
Jake:要不行
Jake: Why not.
Jake:妙啊靠
Jake: Brilliant, damn.
Lucia: 哎遇事不好
Lucia: Oh, things aren't going well.
Lucia: 咱这有铅笔吗
Lucia: Do we have a pencil?
Jake:没有铅笔可以买点
Jake: No pencils, we can buy some.
Shure:  昨天昨天晚上怎么偷偷发红包呢
Shure: Why did you secretly send red envelopes last night?
Jake:那就发工资
Jake: Then let's issue the salaries.
Jake:哎工资还没发完呢
Jake: Oh, the salaries aren't fully paid yet.
Lucia: 突然来真的
Lucia: Suddenly, it's for real.
Shure:  哈哈哈对突然变成抢的了
Shure: Haha yeah, suddenly it's a scramble.
Shure:  我靠哈哈哈
Shure: Damn, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  昨天晚上睡亏了
Shure: Missed out while sleeping last night.
Shure:  睡没100块钱哈哈哈
Shure: Missed a hundred bucks while sleeping, haha.
Shure:  卧槽这觉睡的
Shure: Damn, what a sleep.
Shure:  我从来没感觉我自己一宿这么值钱过
Shure: Never felt so valuable in my sleep before.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  慢慢
Shure: Slowly.
Shure:  记得那一首歌
Shure: Remember that song?
Jake:那个金币是买的对吧
Jake: Those coins were bought, right?
Jake:金币就是买的贴纸
Jake: The coins were bought for stickers.
Lucia: 贴纸对今天到
Lucia: Stickers, arriving today.
Jake:那OK就是贴
Jake: Then OK, just stickers.
Shure:  一说到贴纸
Shure: Speaking of stickers.
Jake:OK纯贴纸
Jake: OK, pure stickers.
Shure:  我还有点伴手礼
Shure: I still have some souvenirs.
Jake:伴手礼
Jake: A souvenir.
Jake:当伴郎去了
Jake: Went to be a groomsman.
Shure:  什么哈哈
Shure: What? Haha.
Shure:  什么烂梗啊
Shure: What a lame joke.
Katrina:  啥呀
Katrina: What?
Katrina:  这是什么
Katrina: What's this?
Shure:  这是我们乐队LOGO的贴纸
Shure: This is a sticker of our band logo.
Shure:  哇周边产品
Shure: Wow, it's a merch.
Katrina:  你们好正啊
Katrina: You guys are so legit.
Lucia: 你们这个贴纸好客系啊
Lucia: Your stickers are so welcoming.
Shure:  是的这LOGO花3,000块钱设计的
Shure: Yeah, this logo cost us 3,000 yuan to design.
Jake:啊为什么为什么不送我啊呵
Jake: Ah, why didn't you give me one, haha.
Shure:  送的送的都送了
Shure: We did, we gave them all out.
Jake:这什么呀你叫什么呀
Jake: What is it? What's it called?
Shure:  百鸟辞典
Shure: Hundred Birds Dictionary.
Shure:  这个大概也符合这个元素我感觉
Shure: I think it fits the theme pretty well.
Jake:百鸟辞典为什么呀他怎么3
Jake: Hundred Birds Dictionary, why? How did 3
Jake:这这3,000块钱给你什么解释了吗
Jake: Did the 3,000 yuan give you any explanation?
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈你讲讲
Jake: Hahaha, tell me about it.
Shure:  没有我感觉让GPG升升也差不多
Shure: No, I just think it lifts GPG, that's about it.
Jake:不是他他为什么你给我讲讲呗
Jake: No, why? Tell me.
Jake:为什么长这样啊
Jake: Why does it look like this?
Shure:  就是哎呀
Shure: Well, ugh.
Shure:  我我也不会讲
Shure: I-I can't explain it.
Jake:哈哈哈他也没给你讲是吧
Jake: Hahaha, he didn't explain it to you, did he?
Shure:  对我这东西真的只可意会不可言传
Shure: Right, it's something you have to feel, not explain.
Jake:哈哈哈干反
Jake: Hahaha, look at it the other way.
Shure:  看反了看反了
Shure: You got it upside down.
Lucia: 雨轩我查了一下如果这样但是
Lucia: Yuxuan, I checked, if it's like this...
Lucia: 如果这个花就是有这个花屁股的话
Lucia: If this flower has a backside...
Lucia: 对不起戳到了
Lucia: Sorry, I poked it.
Lucia: 就是花瓣的那个压力就不够
Lucia: The pressure on the petals wouldn't be enough.
Lucia: 因为他这个
Lucia: Because...
Lucia: 我就会把那个压的东西托起来一点
Lucia: I would lift the thing that's pressing it a bit.
Lucia: 嗯嗯所以就花瓣就是皱的
Lucia: Mm-hmm, so the petals would wrinkle.
Jake:那我觉得GBT应该能给你画出来
Jake: I think GBT can draw it out for you.
Lucia: 垫一个厚纸巾或者是之类的
Lucia: Put a thick tissue or something under it.
Lucia: 可能就是施加到花瓣上的压力不够
Lucia: Maybe the pressure on the petals isn't enough.
Lucia: 所以他就水
Lucia: So it gets watery.
Lucia: 就是一脱水他自己就慢慢缩起来
Lucia: 对就让他跟中间的这个厚度一样
Lucia: 或者就像你说的把花瓣撕下来
Lucia: 然后但是那样的话
Lucia: 我们是不是到时候要给他自己粘起来
Katrina:  那样的话就得自己拼成一个花的形状
Lucia: 麻烦啊
Katrina:  对啊我看他们
Katrina:  怎么就直接能压成一个花瓣的样子
Katrina:  他们人呢其他的
Lucia: 嗯可心刚才在外面
Lucia: 然后微微我也不知道
Lucia: 在楼上吗
Jake:我问问我看看去
Jake:干啥呢
Jake:what are you doing
Tasha: 我感觉大家没有干什么哎
Jake:确实没干是吧
Jake:对
Jake:收拾收拾
Jake: Tidy up.
Jake:呃你装饰房间压压花
Jake: Uh, you can decorate the room with some pressed flowers.
Jake:就是这些
Jake: That's pretty much it.
Jake:对然后一块玩狗去
Jake: Yeah, then let's go play with the dog.
Jake:快递来了你好拆对吧
Jake: The delivery is here, right? You can open it.
Jake:好还没有
Jake: Alright, not yet.
Tasha: 来了吗
Tasha: Is it here?
Jake:等来了去拆快递
Jake: Wait till it arrives, then open it.
Jake:然后今天是谷雨
Jake: And today is Grain Rain.
Jake:谷雨要干什么呀
Tasha: 谷雨
Tasha: Grain Rain?
Jake:一个节气
Jake: It's a solar term.
Tasha: 我不知道哈哈哈你搜一搜嘛
Tasha: I don't know, haha, look it up.
Jake:好搜一搜
Jake: Okay, I'll look it up.
Jake:问问GPT吧
Jake: Let's ask GPT.
Tasha: 谷雨节气习俗药产品单走谷雨
Tasha: Grain Rain traditions, medicinal products, single walk on Grain Rain...
Jake:吃三色饭
Jake: Eating three-color rice.
Jake:三色饭
Jake: Three-color rice.
Tasha: 嗯人家那种糙米饭
Tasha: Hmm, like that brown rice.
Tasha: 吃香菜我不过这个节日靠
Tasha: Eating cilantro... I don't celebrate this holiday, ugh.
Jake:那就点个三盒饭吧
Jake: Then let's order three lunch boxes.
Jake:午饭
Jake: For lunch.
Lucia: 比较适合比较适合压那种小的
Lucia: It's more suitable for pressing small ones.
Tasha: 你要不要做个店
Tasha: Do you want to open a shop?
Jake:我可以不做
Jake: I don't have to do it.
Jake:留给你做
Jake: I'll leave it for you to do.
Jake:啊这就是三色饭吗
Jake: Ah, is this the three-colored rice?
Jake:哈哈我靠
Jake: Haha, oh my god.
Jake:什么叫三色番
Jake: What do you mean by three-colored rice?
Tasha: 我觉得应该就是白米红米和黑米吧
Tasha: I think it means white rice, red rice, and black rice.
Jake:问问PPT
Jake: Ask about the PPT.
Tasha: 帮我继续一遍安安网
Tasha: Help me continue with An An Net.
Jake:呃今天是谷雨
Jake: Uh, today is Grain Rain.
Jake:谷雨这个节气一般吃什么呢
Jake: What do people generally eat during Grain Rain?
Tasha: 唱的还挺好听的
Tasha: The singing is quite good.
Tasha: 这是不是疯了
Tasha: Is this person crazy?
Jake:看看去求求去
Jake: Let's go and have a look.
Shure: 你在让GPT干嘛哦
Shure: What are you asking GPT to do?
Jake:没有呃
Jake: Nothing, uh.
Jake:就问他故意吃什么
Jake: Just asking what to eat on purpose.
Jake:刚刚我在楼上
Jake: Just now, I was upstairs.
Jake:以为下面你们谁在唱这个呢唱挺好
Jake: I thought someone downstairs was singing this, sounded quite good.
Jake:呵我这下个PPT它卡了
Jake: Haha, my PPT is stuck.
AI：食物和习俗
AI: Food and customs.
AI ：一般来说
AI: Generally speaking,
Jake:人们会选择吃一些应季的食物
Jake:来庆祝这个节目
Jake: To celebrate this festival.
Jake:呵呵呵是吧
Jake: Haha, right?
Jake:这么这么带范
Jake: That's quite stylish.
Jake:这个话说则吃之
Jake: This phrase means to eat it.
AI ：豆腐炖青菜
AI: Tofu stewed with greens.
AI：这道菜简单清淡
AI: This dish is simple and light.
AI：有助于清除体内湿气
AI: It helps to remove moisture from the body.
AI：二香椿
AI: And Chinese toon.
Jake:香椿
Jake: Chinese toon.
Jake:是豆腐心菜
Jake: It's tofu with heart greens.
Shure:  我感觉是胡诌
Shure: I feel like it's nonsense.
Jake:我也去
Jake: Me too.
Jake:这玩意还得上百度
Jake: This thing still needs Baidu.
Jake:GOOGLE都不行
Jake: Google won't work.
Jake:确实呵呵
Jake: Indeed, haha.
Shure:  真的是百度才能要
Shure: Only Baidu can help with this.
Shure:  不问闻心意言吧
Shure: Don't ask, just follow the instructions.
Jake:啊这个确实
Jake: Ah, that's true.
Jake:这个模板他都写好了应该
Jake: The template should be already written.
Jake:你有吗文熙一言
Jake: Do you have it, Wenxi?
Shure:  我好像有
Shure: I think I do.
Jake:呵呵给我整一个
Jake: Haha, give me one.
Shure:  我试一下
Shure: Let me try.
Jake:没有
Jake: Nope.
Jake:不能吧还是问百度吧
Jake: Maybe we should ask Baidu after all.
Jake:小度小度
Jake: Xiao Du, Xiao Du.
Shure:  居然真没用
Shure: It really doesn't work.
Shure:  抖音旗下还有个叫豆包的
Shure: Douyin also has another app called Doubao.
Jake:纪仓颉
Jake: Ji Cangjie.
Jake:喝谷雨茶
Jake: Drink Guyu tea.
Shure:  谷雨茶是啥
Shure: What's Guyu tea?
Shure:  我们点要不咱们点点奶茶吧今天
Shure: How about we order some milk tea today?
Jake:可以哈哈
Jake: Sure, haha.
Shure:  我靠好久没喝了
Shure: Wow, it's been a while since I had some.
Jake:2春茶
Jake: Spring tea.
Jake:一定得是上午采的茶
Jake: It has to be tea picked in the morning.
Shure:  记得那一首歌
Shure: Remember that song?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:要挎着篮子到野外走来走去
Jake: You have to carry a basket and walk around in the wild.
Jake:就叫走胡语
Jake: It's called "walking with Hu language."
Jake:那我们就去玩狗去吧哈哈哈
Jake: So let's go play with the dog, haha.
Jake:要杀五毒
Jake: You have to kill five poisons.
Jake:要看到苍蝇得打
Jake: If you see a fly, you have to swat it.
Jake:这是什么习俗吗
Jake: Is this some kind of custom?
Shure:  看我这两天把我的号养成什么样了
Shure: Look at what I've done with my account in the past few days.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina:  呵呵呵养成非摇滚了
Katrina: Haha, it's not rock at all.
Jake:你为什么要用你的号来登他
Jake: Why are you using your account to log in for him?
Jake:换个号换个号
Jake: Switch accounts, switch accounts.
Shure: 没有没有会员啊
Shure: I don't have a membership.
Jake:哦这么回事
Jake: Oh, I see.
Jake:那他也有模式吧
Jake: But it also has a mode, right?
Shure: （歌词）感情就像危险卑微的地方等等等我
Shure: (Lyrics) Emotions are like dangerous and humble places, wait for me.
Katrina:  真的是这样的吗
Katrina: Is it really like that?
Katrina:  我的步骤没有错哎
Katrina: My steps are not wrong, you know.
Jake:饺子你能吃几个呀
Jake: How many dumplings can you eat?
Katrina:  我我今天估计只能吃8个
Katrina: I think I can only eat 8 today.
Jake:18个你是吃几个呀
Jake: Out of 18, how many can you eat?
Jake:我10个 15个
Jake: I can eat 10 or 15.
Shure:  十十个吧
Shure: Ten, ten.
Shure:  你就按10个
Shure: Just count 10.
Jake:10个行
Jake: 10 is fine.
Jake:按10个算
Jake: Count it as 10.
Jake:再整点饼
Jake: Let's get some more pancakes.
Jake:还有那种什么叫叫香椿饼
Jake: And also, what's that called, Chinese toon pancakes?
Jake:你知道吧
Jake: You know, right?
Shure:  不知道一种植物
Shure: I don't know, it's a kind of plant.
Jake:一种植物
Jake: It's a kind of plant.
Shure:  香椿啊香椿我知道
Shure: Chinese toon, yeah, I know.
Jake:香椿对
Jake: Chinese toon, right.
Shure:  应该什么
Shure: Should be...
Shure:  你今天能吃几个饺子
Shure: How many dumplings can you eat today?
Shure:  100个哈哈哈
Shure: 100, haha.
Jake:那你不吃
Jake: Then you don't eat.
Jake:你不吃完不准走
Jake: You can't leave until you finish.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure:  没看过那个什么那个视频吗
Shure: Haven't you watched that video?
Jake:没有啥玩意
Jake: No, what is it?
Shure:  那个
Shure: That one.
Shure:  你感觉今天数学能考多少分
Shure: How many points do you think you can get in math today?
Shure:  80分然后啪下的卷59分呵呵
Shure: 80 points, and then boom, it turns out to be 59, haha.
(歌词)there are places i remember my life
(Lyrics) There are places I remember in my life
(歌词)you're so happy forever not forever
(Lyrics) You're so happy forever, not forever
(歌词)some have gone and some remain
(Lyrics) Some have gone and some remain
(歌词)all these places have turned moments
(Lyrics) All these places have their moments
(歌词)with lovers and friends i still can recall
(Lyrics) With lovers and friends I still can recall
(歌词)some are dead and some are living
(Lyrics) Some are dead and some are living
(歌词) i love them all
(Lyrics) I love them all
(歌词)oh with all these friends and lovers
(Lyrics) Oh, with all these friends and lovers
(歌词)there is no one compares with you
(Lyrics) There is no one compares with you
(歌词)and these memories lose their meaning
(Lyrics) And these memories lose their meaning
(歌词)when i think of love as something new
(Lyrics) When I think of love as something new
(歌词)and i know i'll never lose affection
(Lyrics) And I know I'll never lose affection
(歌词)cause you're my friend
(Lyrics) 'Cause you're my friend
(歌词)you know i want something about that my life
(Lyrics) you know i want something about that my life
(歌词)i love you more
(Lyrics) i love you more
Lucia: 那样的灯
Lucia: That kind of lamp
Lucia: 然后但是那种水波纹灯
Lucia: And then there's that kind of ripple lamp
Lucia: 我觉得就是
Lucia: I think it's just
Lucia: 好像它效果都不是那么好看
Lucia: It doesn't look that good
Lucia: 如果好看的话就特别贵
Lucia: If it looks good, it's super expensive
Lucia: 是的就大概得一二百那种
Lucia: Yeah, it probably costs a couple hundred bucks
Lucia: 然后我觉得
Lucia: And I think
Lucia: 哎呀这个这个小灯好像不必要那么贵
Lucia: Oh, this little lamp doesn't need to be so expensive
Lucia: 然后我就就换了一个小夜灯
Lucia: So I just got a small night light instead
Lucia: 但那个夜灯因为是在京东上
Lucia: But that night light, since it's from JD
Lucia: 所以没有淘宝上便宜的
Lucia: It's not as cheap as the ones on Taobao
Alice: 我有几个在拼多多上买的
Alice: I bought a few from Pinduoduo
Alice: 拼多多也很适合买那种小小的东西
Alice: Pinduoduo is also good for buying those small things
Lucia: 拼多多的话
Lucia: As for Pinduoduo
Lucia: 他他能就是比较快的送到吗
Lucia: Does it deliver quickly?
Alice: 不一定就跟淘宝里差不多
Alice: Not necessarily, it's about the same as Taobao
Jake:我都没在拼多多上买过东西谢谢
Jake: I've never bought anything from Pinduoduo, thanks
Jake:来来吧
Jake: Let's go
Jake:呃要吧要要要每天每天都要
Jake: Uh, yeah, yeah, every day, every day
Alice: 你没有用过拼多多吗
Alice: You've never used Pinduoduo?
Jake:我没有用过
Jake: I've never used it
Jake:要不就放
Jake: Or just put it
Jake:哎就放放客厅吧
Jake: Oh, just put it in the living room
Jake:要不放放客厅放客厅放客厅
Jake: Or put it in the living room, the living room, the living room
Jake:拍拍得了
Jake: Just put it there
Jake:要不放二楼去
Jake: Or put it on the second floor
Jake:放二楼拆吧位置大一点也可以
Jake: Put it on the second floor, there's more space, that's fine too
Jake:放二楼桌上
Jake: Put it on the table on the second floor
Jake:拆吧要不好
Jake: Unpack it, otherwise it's no good
Lucia: 要不好一楼用的东西在一楼拆
Lucia: Or else, unpack the stuff for the first floor on the first floor
Lucia: 二楼用的东西在二楼拆
Lucia: Unpack the stuff for the second floor on the second floor
Lucia: 要不然话都搬上去
Lucia: Otherwise, you'll have to move everything up
Lucia: 然后再搬下来对吧
Lucia: And then move it down again, right?
Lucia: 大家可以认领一下自己的快递
Lucia: Everyone can claim their own packages
Lucia: 剩下都得明天才能到好嘞
Lucia: The rest won't arrive until tomorrow, okay
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay
Jake:怎么了
Jake: What's wrong?
Jake:谁谁不好意思微微
Jake: Who, who, sorry, Tasha
Jake:为什么不好意思
Jake: Why are you embarrassed?
Jake:你快递有单号的话你可以群里面问他
Jake: If you have the tracking number, you can ask them in the group.
Alice: 快递就这些吗
Alice: Is that all the packages?
Lucia: 有的可能
Lucia: Maybe.
Lucia: 是不是还没到
Lucia: Are they not here yet?
Jake:是不是还没到
Jake: Are they not here yet?
Alice: 我的到了呀他没有帮我拿呀
Alice: Mine arrived, but he didn't help me get it.
Jake:那你就在群里面干他
Jake: Then confront him in the group.
Lucia: battle一下对
Lucia: Have a battle, right.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Jake:你们会说家乡话吗
Jake: Can you speak your hometown dialect?
Lucia: 会啊
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 但是北方话
Lucia: But it's a northern dialect.
Lucia: 其实就是普通话基础上变个调
Lucia: It's basically just a variation of Mandarin.
Jake:是确实
Jake: That's true.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:你挡着了
Jake: You're blocking.
Alice: 没有啊
Alice: No, I'm not.
Jake:刚刚变调的话
Jake: Speaking of variations...
Alice: 我的调很准
Alice: My tone is accurate.
Alice: 但是如果说就是专有的一些
Alice: But if we're talking about specific terms...
Alice: 那啥
Alice: Like...
Alice: 就是
Alice: Just...
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice: 我能听出来谁是郑州的谁不是郑州的
Alice: I can tell who is from Zhengzhou and who isn't.
Alice: 就是那种河南话
Alice: Like that Henan dialect.
Alice: 不是也分区的吗
Alice: Doesn't it have different regions?
Jake:哦分多少区
Jake: Oh, how many regions?
Lucia: 那已经很厉害了我根本
Lucia: That's pretty impressive, I can't...
Alice: 这个很难界定吧
Alice: It's hard to define, right?
Alice: 是一个连续统
Alice: It's a continuum.
Jake:那陕西会分吗
Jake: Does Shaanxi have divisions too?
Lucia: 会分但我我其实听不出来
Lucia: Yes, but I can't really tell them apart.
Jake:西安和比如说汉中
Jake: Xi'an and, for example, Hanzhong...
Lucia: 对会有区别
Lucia: Yeah, there's a difference.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Lucia: 像我那个
Lucia: Like I...
Lucia: 我有我有
Lucia: I have...
Lucia: 我有舍友然后他们也是陕西人
Lucia: I have roommates and they're also from Shaanxi.
Lucia: 然后我给他们说就我
Lucia: And I told them...
Lucia: 因为我们家就是说普通话比较多
Lucia: Because our family mostly speaks Mandarin.
Lucia: 然后就
Lucia: And then...
Lucia: 只有我姥姥姥爷他们说那个陕
Lucia: Only my grandparents speak that Shaanxi dialect.
Lucia: 对所以就是就是
Lucia: Yeah, so, like...
Lucia: 那有
Lucia: If I...
Lucia: 就是我给他们说的时候
Lucia: When I speak it to them,
Lucia: 我舍友就说啊说你说的是西安话
Lucia: My roommate would say, "Oh, you're speaking Xi'an dialect."
Lucia: 但是就是你让我去听
Lucia: But if you ask me to listen to
Lucia: 不同地区的话的话我听不出来
Lucia: Different regional dialects, I can't tell them apart.
Lucia: 我觉得都一样的
Lucia: They all sound the same to me.
Jake:西安和西安
Jake: Xi'an and Xi'an?
Lucia: 也会有一点点区别吧
Lucia: There might be a slight difference.
Jake:和陕北会有大的差别吗
Jake: And Shaanbei, is there a big difference?
Lucia: 哦好像陕北口音会差别大一点
Lucia: Oh, it seems like the Shaanbei accent is a bit more different.
Lucia: 就是陕北会
Lucia: Like, Shaanbei...
Jake:哦这就是我们要摆甜品的东西嗯
Jake: Oh, this is where we put the desserts, hmm.
Alice: 是有点味道吧
Alice: It has a bit of a smell, right?
Jake:今天没太阳
Jake: There's no sun today.
Alice: 今天应该有一点点
Alice: There should be a bit today.
Lucia: 可能是漆味
Lucia: Maybe it's the paint smell.
Jake:我午饭已经买好了
Jake: I've already bought lunch.
Jake:买了对
Jake: Bought it, yes.
Jake:还有那个香椿饼
Jake: Also got some toon pancakes.
Jake:香椿饼香椿饼
Jake: Toon pancakes, toon pancakes.
Jake:今天就是要吃这个东西
Jake: Today, we are eating this.
Alice: 今天是谷雨
Alice: Today is Grain Rain.
Alice: 所以要吃香椿椿菜
Alice: So we eat toon sprouts.
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Alice: 是的
Alice: Yes.
Jake:这就是莫名其妙的多了一个环节
Jake: This is just an extra, random step.
Jake:我也不知道
Jake: I don't know either.
Jake:呵呵呵今天真没有生活品味
Jake: Haha, today really lacks lifestyle taste.
Lucia: 生活总是充满了变化
Lucia: Life is always full of changes.
Jake:对就是充满变化
Jake: Yes, it's full of changes.
Lucia: 对就是充满了变化
Lucia: Yes, it's full of changes.
Tasha: 香椿是什么
Tasha: What's toon?
Alice: 香椿是一种
Alice: Toon is a kind of...
Jake:你肯定知道
Jake: You definitely know it.
Jake:因为我们家那边总还哎
Jake: Because back in our hometown, we still...
Jake:不太是记
Jake: Not quite remember.
Jake:就差不多的东西吧
Jake: Just something like this, I guess.
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake:我也说不上了
Jake: I can't really say.
Alice: 荠菜是地上挖的
Alice: Shepherd's purse is dug from the ground.
Alice: 香椿树上长的
Alice: Chinese toon grows on trees.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:我分不清这野菜
Jake: I can't tell these wild vegetables apart.
Jake:大白菜我也分不清
Jake: I can't even tell apart Chinese cabbage.
Jake:这是感觉这文件放文件呢
Jake: This feels like putting files in a file holder.
Jake:放笔筒笔筒
Jake: Pen holder, pen holder.
Jake:对放文件袋
Jake: Yes, file folder.
Jake:文件夹太好了
Jake: The folder is great.
Tasha: 做完我就带回去放文件夹哈哈哈
Tasha: After I'm done, I'll take it back to put in the folder, haha.
Lucia: 我可以申请瓜分一个吗带回去
Lucia: Can I apply to split one and take it back?
Tasha: 你想要瓜分哪个
Tasha: Which one do you want to split?
Lucia: 可能这个吧
Lucia: Maybe this one.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay.
Jake:好这是什么
Jake: Okay, what's this?
Jake:书架小
Jake: Small bookshelf.
Jake:这这能放小记事本
Jake: This can hold small notebooks.
Lucia: 底下可以放点小东西
Lucia: You can put small things underneath.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 然后上面上面可以放我买那个小夜灯
Lucia: And on top, you can put the small night light I bought.
Lucia: 我打算把那个夜灯给他带回家去
Lucia: I plan to take that night light back home.
Tasha: 这个怎么弄啊
Tasha: How do you do this?
Jake:这是啥呀
Jake: What is this?
Alice: 应该有螺丝可以把那个钉拧上去哦
Alice: There should be screws to fasten it.
Jake:哦哦这个确实
Jake: Oh, oh, that's true.
Lucia: 那您那个您那个
Lucia: So that one, that one.
Jake:我来我来我来那个
Jake: I'll do it, I'll do it.
Tasha: 那个敲螺丝刀没有给
Tasha: Didn't they give a screwdriver?
Jake:那个巧克斯没有给
Jake: They didn't give the screws.
Jake:确实没事
Jake: Really, it's fine.
Lucia: 没事杨老板好多螺丝刀
Lucia: It's okay, Jake has lots of screwdrivers.
Jake:放这吧就一个
Jake: Just put it here, just one.
Jake:哈哈哈啊啊
Jake: Haha, ah ah.
Tasha: 不是还有一个吗
Tasha: Isn't there another one?
Jake:这里面还有两个好像
Jake: There are two more in here, I think.
Jake:希望没有
Jake: Hopefully not.
Alice: 这还有一个够了吗
Alice: There's one more here, is that enough?
Jake:有几个四个
Jake: How many? Four?
Tasha: 这不是三个吗
Tasha: Isn't it three?
Tasha: 这上面还有一个
Tasha: There's another one on top.
Jake:对不起
Jake: Sorry.
Jake:好嘞这个是
Jake: Alright, this is...
Lucia: 这就是单独的吗
Lucia: Is this separate?
Tasha: 嗯好像是
Tasha: Hmm, seems like it.
Tasha: 我也不知道
Tasha: I don't know either.
Jake:今天晒不了太阳
Jake: No sunbathing today.
Jake:有点亏亏的
Jake: Feels like a bit of a loss.
Jake:今天竟吃得出
Jake: Can actually taste it today.
(歌词)：那锐志越来越记挂
(Lyrics): That sharpness lingers more and more
(歌词)：开始时捱一些梦
(Lyrics): Started with some dreams
Katrina:  咱还有多剪刀吗
Katrina: Do we have more scissors?
Katrina:  是不是剪刀不够
Katrina: Are we short on scissors?
Katrina:  他们拆快递都不够
Katrina: They don't have enough to open packages.
Jake:嗯嗯嗯无言问
Jake: Hmm, hmm, hmm, speechless.
(歌词)：不似你太坏
(Lyrics): Unlike you being too bad
(歌词)：青春的晚餐似夜场迷惑你那一家
(Lyrics): The dinner of youth is like a night scene enchanting that place
(歌词)：我想要微雨中漫游
(Lyrics): I want to wander in the drizzle
(歌词)：想找世界上的花都在夜晚之中
(Lyrics): Searching for flowers in the night
(歌词)：我愿意升华想
(Lyrics): I want to elevate my thoughts
Jake:有用吧
Jake: Useful, right?
(歌词) ：他愿做人没有苦涩可以吗
(Lyrics): Can he live without bitterness?
(歌词)：真想不到当初我们也讨厌吃苦瓜
(Lyrics): Who would've thought we also hated bitter melon back then
(歌词)：当睇清世间所求定理又何用再怕
(Lyrics): Once you understand the world's principles, there's no need to fear
(歌词)：珍惜淡定的心境苦过后更加清
(Lyrics): Cherish the calm heart, clearer after bitterness
(歌词)：万般过去难逃避但有领会留花
(Lyrics): All past can't be avoided but enlightenment remains
(歌词) ：今天是你约定在神说这叫做青蛙
(Lyrics): Today you agreed to what God said is called a frog
(歌词)：爱似戏剧般的你明显不会及她吗
(Lyrics): Love is like a drama, won't you be as good as her?
Jake:这是我22年年底就是在米
Jake: This was at the end of '22, just in Mi...
Tasha: 小米是吗
Tasha: Xiaomi, right?
Jake:是吗小米
Jake: Really? Xiaomi?
Lucia: 这是你那个超高级的起子吗
Jake:对这不是小米
Jake: No, this isn't Xiaomi.
Jake:这我也不知道是什么玩意
Jake: I don't know what this thing is.
Jake:就就是呃 22年
Jake: Just... um, '22.
Tasha: 小米也有
Tasha: Xiaomi has it too.
Jake:你嗯挺多的这种东西
Jake: You have quite a lot of these things.
Jake:嗯那年隔离回国
Jake: Hmm, that year quarantined back home.
Jake:隔离在酒店里边
Jake: Quarantine in the hotel
Tasha: 这是干嘛的
Tasha: What's this for?
Tasha: 这是不同的头吗
Tasha: Are these different heads?
Jake:对拆电脑的
Jake: Yes, for taking apart the computer
Jake:当时把我麦克给拆了
Jake: At that time, they took apart my mic
Jake:然后拆了没装回去
Jake: Then took it apart and didn't put it back together
Jake:哈哈哈最后变成个台式机啊
Jake: Haha, in the end, it became a desktop
Jake:没有就把它给散了
Jake: No, just disassembled it
Jake:你知道散装了
Jake: You know, it was in pieces
Jake:哦行吧
Jake: Oh, fine
Lucia: 散装但依然能用
Lucia: Disassembled but still usable
Jake:散装能用
Jake: Disassembled but usable
Tasha: 哇这这怎么不算一种赛博朋克呢
Tasha: Wow, isn't this a kind of cyberpunk?
Jake:装不回去
Jake: Can't put it back together
Jake:哈哈哈太赛博了
Jake: Haha, too cyberpunk
Jake:这个行吧
Jake: This is fine
Lucia: 哇行吧
Lucia: Wow, okay
Alice: 这个就是不同的头都有
Alice: This has different heads
Lucia: 我修我修过
Lucia: I repaired, I fixed it
Lucia: 我修电脑干过最大的工程
Lucia: The biggest repair I did on my computer
Lucia: 就是给自己加装内存条
Lucia: Was adding more RAM to it
Lucia: 剩下我啥都不敢干
Lucia: I didn't dare to do anything else
Lucia: 因为我要是拆了我就装不回去了
Lucia: Because if I took it apart, I couldn't put it back together
Jake:当时为了换了几个键盘键
Jake: At that time, I replaced a few keyboard keys
Jake:然后把整个外壳给拆了
Jake: And ended up taking the whole case apart
Lucia: 但是您把它拆了还得组装成台式机
Lucia: But you disassembled it and turned it into a desktop
Lucia: 这我真没想到
Lucia: I really didn't expect that
Lucia: 怎么凭空还多了一些零件呢
Lucia: How did extra parts appear out of nowhere?
Jake:没有就是全部散开
Jake: No, it was all disassembled
Lucia: 就是装回去发现零件多了
Lucia: When you put it back together, you found extra parts
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Alice: 这确实香椿饼是你点的吗
Alice: By the way, did you order the Chinese toon pancake?
Shure:  不是
Shure: No
Jake:呃算是
Jake: Uh, sort of
Jake:呃百度文信一年都没开
Jake: Uh, Baidu Wenxin hasn't been open for a year
Shure:  他问百度的
Shure: He asked Baidu
Jake:呵呵百度对
Jake: Haha, Baidu, yes
Jake:只能问百度
Jake: Can only ask Baidu
Jake:这个
Jake: This one
Shure:  这谷雨要吃啥
Shure: What does Gu Yu want to eat?
Tasha: 香椿饼啊
Tasha: Chinese toon pancakes, huh?
Jake:对他没说饺子
Jake: Right, he didn't mention dumplings.
Jake:但是我们还是点
Jake: But we're ordering them anyway.
Shure:  因为饺子总不会错的
Shure: Because dumplings can never go wrong.
Shure:  毕竟好吃不过饺子
Shure: After all, nothing beats dumplings.
Jake:这个对
Jake: That's right.
Alice: 我还以为香椿饼是专门点的
Alice: I thought the Chinese toon pancakes were specially ordered.
Jake:是是专门点
Jake: Yes, they were specially ordered.
Jake:就是对问了百度说今儿应该吃点啥
Jake: We just asked Baidu what we should eat today.
Jake:今天还有叫逛谷雨还是走谷雨
Jake:什么玩意
Jake: What the heck is that?
Jake:走谷雨就是拿
Tasha: 那我要拿那个
Tasha: Then I want to take that.
Katrina:  那我们去撸狗吧
Katrina: Then let's go pet some dogs.
Shure:  对我们就拿着个
Shure: Yeah, let's just take that...
Jake:对对对是哎这啥呀
Jake: Yeah, yeah, what is that?
Shure:  然后唱着采蘑菇的小姑娘哈哈
Shure: And then we sing "The Little Mushroom Picker" haha.
Lucia: 我特别喜欢这个颜色哦
Lucia: I really like this color.
Lucia: 感觉很好看
Lucia: It looks really nice.
Jake:我要把它给先拿出来
Jake: I want to take it out first.
Tasha: 这写的什么乱七八糟的
Tasha: What a mess this is written in.
Lucia: 希拉维
Lucia: "C'est la vie".
Tasha: 是吗这什么语
Tasha: Really? What language is this?
Lucia: 法语哦
Lucia: It's French.
Jake:法语OK
Tasha: 对不起
Tasha: Sorry.
Lucia: 但这个c这是不是写错了
Lucia: But this "c", isn't it written wrong?
Lucia: 应该是CES
Lucia: It should be "CES".
Jake:是哪个我法语不好
Jake:麻痹知道生活别的不
Jake: Honestly, knowing life is enough.
Jake:人人是吧
Jake: Right, everyone?
Jake:好像是这就是生活OK you
Jake: Seems like this is life, okay you...
Lucia: no是我们
Lucia: No, it's "we".
Jake:OK
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 我们的组合
Lucia: Our group.
Jake:OK
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 如果只有一个日的话
Lucia: If there's only one "日", it means "day" or "today".
Lucia: 就是就是白天或者今天的意思
Lucia: Just like, it means "day" or "today".
Alice: 法语是表音的文字吗
Alice: Is French a phonetic language?
Lucia: 是啊
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 呃不是吗
Lucia: Uh, isn't it?
Lucia: 不是你是圆形的
Lucia: No, you're the round one.
Alice: 不是不是我不是我
Alice: No, no, it's not me.
Alice: 我没我不知道啊
Alice: I don't know!
Lucia: 应该是吧
Lucia: It should be, right?
Lucia: 像他们这些拉丁语系的
Lucia: Like those Latin-based languages.
Lucia: 应该都是表音的
Lucia: They should all be phonetic.
Jake:看不太懂
Jake: I can't really understand.
Jake:应该都就中文
Jake: It should all be in Chinese.
Jake:还有谁吧
Jake: Who else?
Lucia: 东亚地区就这些语言
Lucia: In East Asia, it's just these languages.
Jake:哎就是另一个
Jake: Ah, it's the other one.
Tasha: 另一个那个呢
Tasha: What about the other one?
Tasha: 螺丝呢
Tasha: What about the screws?
Jake:没了呀嗯
Jake: There aren't any left.
Jake:在这放回去
Jake: Put it back here.
Tasha: 这人也太抠了
Tasha: This person is so stingy.
Tasha: 就发4螺丝
Tasha: Only gave 4 screws.
Shure:  给你一个特别好看的纯爱
Shure: I'll give you a really nice romance.
Jake:丢了粘上
Jake: Lost it, stick it on.
Jake:我们有很多双面胶胶
Jake: We have a lot of double-sided tape.
Jake:摄像头的双面胶都很给力都很猛
Jake: The double-sided tape for the camera is really strong.
Lucia: 哇真猛啊
Lucia: Wow, it's really strong.
Jake:很猛啊对
Jake: Yeah, very strong.
Lucia: 你看过罗翔的那个刑法视频
Lucia: Have you seen Luo Xiang's criminal law videos?
Jake:哦我看过
Jake: Oh, I've seen them.
Lucia: 警察局局长从旁边过
Lucia: The police chief walks by.
Lucia: 说好猛啊
Lucia: Says, "So strong!"
Jake:哈哈哈好猛啊
Jake: Hahaha, so strong!
Tasha: 是这个哦
Tasha: Is it this one?
Jake:哈哈好猛啊
Jake: Hahaha, so strong!
Jake:我法语基本上是看剧学的
Lucia: 所以就是一旦不是台词
Lucia: So if it's not lines...
Jake:要不翻译一下
Jake: How about translating it?
Jake:就是拿手机翻译一下
Jake: Just use your phone to translate it.
Lucia: 但谷歌翻译在国内用不上
Lucia: But Google Translate doesn't work in China.
Jake:咱不是对啊
Jake: We're not...
Jake:你你现在
Jake: You, you now...
Jake:你们现在不是了
Jake:就在这个墙外
Jake: You're outside the wall.
Jake:墙外墙内不是一个体系
Jake: The inside and outside walls are two different systems.
Lucia: 这个比较容易看懂
Lucia: This is pretty easy to understand.
Jake:这是什么
Jake: What is this?
Jake:咖啡豆不是这样的哦
Jake: Coffee beans aren't like this.
Lucia: 是不是不太对啊
Lucia: Is this not quite right?
Lucia: 100%阿拉提卡咖啡
Lucia: 100% Arabica coffee.
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK OK.
Tasha: 哪里有咖啡
Tasha: Where's the coffee?
Tasha: 我是说盒子上应该印
Tasha: I mean, it should be printed on the box.
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: It's fine.
Jake: 咖啡豆
Jake: Coffee beans.
Lucia: 我们可以假装
Lucia: We can pretend.
Jake:是咖啡豆
Jake: Coffee beans.
Jake:咖啡咖啡豆
Jake: Coffee, coffee beans.
Jake:是吧哈哈哈
Jake: Right? Haha.
Jake:这个是音译
Jake: This is a transliteration.
Jake:纯音译这是
Jake: Pure transliteration.
Jake:这是哪国语了
Jake: Which language is this?
Jake:西语
Jake: Spanish.
Lucia: 不是吧我不知道
Lucia: No way, I don't know.
Jake:我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Tasha: 你说这盒子里能放什么好吃的呢
Tasha: What do you think we can put in this box that's tasty?
Tasha: 这不是开玩笑嘛
Tasha: Isn't this a joke?
Jake:这个还得晒晒对吧
Jake: This still needs some sun, right?
Jake:吹一吹吧
Jake: Let's air it out.
Tasha: 我就把这两盒子拿走
Tasha: I'll take these two boxes.
Tasha: 这样子放还比较好放
Tasha: It's easier to place them this way.
Jake:嗯那我刚刚干嘛了
Jake: Hmm, what was I doing earlier?
Jake:也行吧哈哈
Jake: That's fine, haha.
Jake:这个可以放在旁边
Jake: This can go on the side.
Jake:当装饰啊
Jake: As decoration.
Tasha: 这个可以单独的
Tasha: This can be separate.
Tasha: 这样子啊
Tasha: Like this.
Jake:对对对看来我们东西有很多啊
Jake: Right, right, looks like we have a lot of stuff.
Jake:很多很多
Jake: A lot, a lot.
Alice: 这个适合放口红
Alice: This is perfect for lipstick.
Alice: 还带分装格
Alice: It even has partitions.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 这个放进去可以放那个什么放什么
Lucia: You can put whatever in here, like...
Lucia: 耳环耳钉这种小首饰
Lucia: Earrings, studs, small jewelry.
Tasha: 好好太好了
Tasha: Great, this is awesome.
Lucia: 特别棒首饰盒放桌子上还不占地方
Lucia: It's fantastic. The jewelry box on the table doesn’t take up much space.
Tasha: 扇一扇
Tasha: Fan it a bit.
Lucia: 我们已经给他想好
Lucia: We've already thought it through.
Alice:就是以后他以后的归宿了
Alice: It's like his future place, in the future.
Tasha: 这个呢装可爱
Tasha: This one’s for being cute.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha
Jake:这怎么装可爱
Jake: How is this cute?
Jake:这什么玩意啊
Jake: What is this thing?
Lucia: 他比较可爱
Lucia: It's quite cute.
Jake:这小房子是吧
Jake: This little house, right?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 像那种爆钟的那个啊
Tasha: Like one of those cuckoo clocks.
Jake:装可爱啊
Jake: Cute, huh?
Alice: 他可以勾住勾住好像
Alice: You can hook it, like...
Lucia: 对是的给里面放个放个圆
Lucia: Yes, put a round one inside.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 那个啥墙时钟
Lucia: Like a wall clock.
Jake:那个啥放墙上放墙上
Jake: Put it on the wall, put it on the wall.
Lucia: 然后在上面再放一个小鸟
Lucia: And then put a little bird on top.
Jake:挺好
Jake: Nice.
Lucia: 好这个的日后归宿也想好了
Lucia: Okay, we've figured out its future place.
Lucia: 那俩盘不用给他想什么
Lucia: No need to think about the two plates.
Lucia: 因为都挺都很常见很好用
Lucia: Because they are pretty common and very useful.
Alice: 这个是不是也能可以养小蜘蛛
Alice: Can this one also be used to raise little spiders?
Alice: 一人一个隔间
Alice: One per compartment.
Jake:呵呵呵会爬出来吧
Jake: Hahaha, they might crawl out.
Lucia: 太小了
Lucia: Too small.
Jake:这个可以养
Jake: This one can be used.
Lucia: 对狼猪会爬出来
Lucia: Yes, the wolf pig might crawl out.
Alice: 就是我想养蛇
Alice: I want to raise a snake.
Lucia: 我也想养蛇
Lucia: I want to raise a snake too.
Alice: 喜欢养栖动物
Alice: I like raising reptiles.
Lucia: 对我也想养蛇
Lucia: Yes, I want to raise a snake too.
Lucia: 但是我之前我还有一个学长
Lucia: But before, I had a senior...
Tasha: 他在养那个什么守宫守宫啊蜥蜴守宫啊
Tasha: He was raising geckos, geckos and lizards.
Tasha: 然后每天他的手上就爬着一条蛇
Tasha: And every day he had a snake crawling on his hand.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 然后肩上还趴着一条
Tasha: And another one resting on his shoulder.
Tasha: 有点吓人
Tasha: It was a bit scary.
Lucia: 我也想养蛇
Lucia: I also want to raise a snake.
Jake:挺厉害
Jake: That's pretty cool.
Jake:囊珠多大呀
Jake: How big can they get?
Lucia: 就看你买的多大
Lucia: It depends on what you buy.
Lucia: 也可以你也可以从这么小开始养
Lucia: You can start with a really small one.
Lucia: 你也可以直接买一个拳头大的
Lucia: Or you can buy one the size of a fist.
Jake:它会变得很大的
Jake: It'll get really big.
Lucia: 对他会蜕皮然后慢慢变得很大
Lucia: Yes, it'll shed its skin and gradually get bigger.
Jake:它最大能到哪
Jake: How big can it get?
Lucia: 最大一般可能超不过大巴掌这么大吧
Lucia: Usually, it won't get bigger than the size of a large hand, I think.
Lucia: 我感觉
Lucia: I feel like.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 因为直接买拳头那么大的
Lucia: Because if you buy one the size of a fist...
Jake:挺好
Jake: That's pretty good.
Lucia: 因为从这么小开始养
Lucia: If you start with a really small one...
Lucia: 很容易中间把它养死
Lucia: It's easy to accidentally kill it.
Jake:它营养不够掉血不知道为啥
Jake: If it doesn't get enough nutrients, it might just die for no reason.
Lucia: 呃不知道为啥就是
Lucia: Uh, yeah, I don't know why either.
Jake:就是好吧
Jake: Okay then.
Jake:要你养几年
Jake: How long do you keep one?
Jake:这个它能活多久
Jake: How long can it live?
Lucia: 能活多久
Lucia: How long can it live?
Lucia: 我也不知道
Lucia: I don't know either.
Lucia: 我经常把
Lucia: I often...
Tasha: 这是干嘛的
Tasha: What's this for?
Jake:不知道
Jake: No idea.
Jake:真不知道
Jake: Really, no idea.
Lucia: 能活能活多久啊
Lucia: How long can it live?
Lucia: 两三年应该不清楚
Lucia: Two or three years maybe, I'm not sure.
Alice: 想养蛇
Alice: I want to raise a snake.
Lucia: 但是蛇要吃老鼠崽子
Lucia: But snakes need to eat baby mice.
Lucia: 对然后那个东西要放冰箱冷藏
Lucia: Yeah, and you need to keep those in the fridge.
Lucia: 我不是很能接受
Lucia: I'm not really okay with that.
Lucia: 他跟我冰箱
Lucia: Sharing my fridge with them.
Lucia: 他跟我共用一个冰箱放吃的
Lucia: Sharing a fridge for food with them.
Alice: 你可以专门给他买个冰箱
Alice: You could buy a separate fridge for them.
Jake:买什么老鼠仔
Jake: Buy baby mice?
Lucia: 舍不得哈哈哈
Lucia: I can't bear to, haha.
Lucia: 太贵了比蛇都贵
Lucia: They're more expensive than the snake.
Jake:老鼠仔是什么
Jake: What are baby mice?
Lucia: 就老鼠崽子
Lucia: Baby mice
Lucia: 那刚出生的老鼠崽子
Lucia: The ones that are just born
Jake:哦然后为什么动起来
Jake: Oh, and why are they moving?
Lucia: 因为要给蛇吃
Lucia: Because they're for feeding snakes
Lucia: 就是你不能让它吃的毒死了吧
Lucia: You can't let the snake eat something poisonous, right?
Jake:它它是活的吗
Jake: Are they alive?
Lucia: 不是就是应该是新鲜的死老鼠
Lucia: No, they should be freshly dead mice
Jake:新鲜的死老鼠
Jake: Freshly dead mice
Jake:为什么不为
Jake: Why not
Jake:为为什么
Jake: Why
Jake:能不能能不能养点活的
Jake: Can't you raise some live ones?
Lucia: 养活老鼠
Lucia: Raise live mice
Jake:养活老鼠
Jake: Raise live mice
Jake:哈哈哈就是给封起来吗
Jake: Hahaha, just keep them sealed up?
Alice: 然后卖哦
Alice: And then sell them
Jake:刚死的活老鼠
Jake: Freshly dead live mice
Lucia: 他一般就是
Lucia: Usually
Lucia: 就是那种爬虫店就会有卖
Lucia: Those reptile shops sell them
Lucia: 各种各样吃的
Lucia: All kinds of food
Lucia: 狼蛛吃的也很那个啥
Lucia: Even stuff for tarantulas
Lucia: 他吃不过那个有的鸟也吃
Lucia: 就那种小虫子
Lucia: Those small bugs.
Lucia: 所以那个还比较好搞
Lucia: So it's easier to handle.
Lucia: 面包虫
Lucia: Mealworms.
Jake:狼猪吃什么
Jake: What do wild boars eat?
Lucia: 就是很多鸟也吃那个
Lucia: A lot of birds eat those too.
Jake:哦我以为吃很多鸟
Jake: Oh, I thought they ate a lot of birds.
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Alice: 谁吃谁还不一定呢
Alice: Who eats who is still uncertain.
Alice: 哈
Alice: Ha.
Katrina:  心灵感应
Katrina: Telepathy.
Jake:拳头这么大应该也能吃一只鸟
Jake: With a fist that big, it could eat a bird too.
Alice: 蜜袋雾也挺好挺可爱的
Alice: Sugar gliders are also quite cute.
Alice: 但是他吃的那个东西我实在是受不了
Alice: But I can't stand what they eat.
Alice: 我我
Alice: I, I...
Jake:那那个是什么东西
Jake: What do they eat?
Alice: 大的那个
Alice: The big ones.
Alice: 大蚕蛹不是大蚕蛹
Alice: Big silkworm pupae, not big silkworm pupae.
Alice: 就是那种
Alice: Just those...
Alice: 说啥呢
Alice: What are you talking about?
Lucia: 哦是那种
Lucia: Oh, it's that kind.
Lucia: 就是就是那个炒的那个是吧
Lucia: It's the stir-fried one, right?
Lucia: 就是
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 人好像也吃
Lucia: People seem to eat it too.
Jake:它是中文吗
Jake: Is it in Chinese?
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Jake:怎么写蜂蜜的
Jake: How do you write "honey"?
Alice: 蜜袋鼠的袋雾
Alice: It's like "sugar glider."
Alice: 就是那个
Alice: It's like that.
Alice: 一个鼠一个无
Alice: One character for "mouse" and one for "none."
Alice: 也不是会飞
Alice: It doesn't fly.
Lucia: 就是它会滑翔
Lucia: It glides.
Alice: 对会滑翔
Alice: Yes, it glides.
Jake:一种鸟
Jake: It's a type of bird.
Lucia: 不是不是一种鸟
Lucia: No, it's not a bird.
Lucia: 它是哺乳动物吧
Lucia: It's a mammal.
Alice: 老鼠吧
Alice: A mouse, right?
Lucia: 应该是那个
Lucia: It should be that.
Alice: 然后他的这个
Alice: And then, like...
Alice: 这个跟他的腿中间有那个翼
Alice: Between its legs, it has that wing.
Alice: 然后就是可以从高处把它扔下来
Alice: So you can throw it from a high place.
Alice: 他就像一个滑翔的效果
Alice: It glides like this.
Alice: 对然后你就可以用比如说他从那里
Alice: Yes, then you can use it, for example, from there.
Jake:蝙蝠的亲戚
Jake: A relative of the bat.
Jake:嗯可以这么理解
Jake: Yeah, you could say that.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Jake:有点像是吧
Jake: Kind of similar, right?
Alice: 但是近亲吧
Alice: But a closer relative.
Alice: 他的表哥表弟
Alice: Like cousins.
Jake:那那他那他最像的
Jake: Then, then, the one it resembles the most...
Jake:我一般常
Jake: The animal I usually see...
Jake:见的动物是老鼠夹蝙蝠
Jake: Is a mix between a mouse and a bat.
Jake:型号好好神奇
Jake: It looks really amazing.
Jake:宝贝也是乖
Jake: Baby is also good.
Alice: 然后比如说从那里飞过来
Alice: Then, for example, it flies from there...
Jake:从那里哈哈哈
Jake: From there, hahaha...
Alice: 哈哈哈从那里飞过来
Alice: Hahaha, it flies from there...
Alice: 然后你就接着他
Alice: Then you catch it.
Alice: 就他这种就特别粘人
Alice: It's very clingy.
Alice: 如果你接不住他他不会摔死
Alice: If you don't catch it, it won't fall to its death.
Alice: 但是他会被气死
Alice: But he's going to be really mad.
Alice: 就是你为什么接不住我呢
Alice: Why can't you catch me?
Alice: 他真的会
Alice: He really will.
Alice: 他会气死
Alice: He'll be furious.
Jake:他生气会干嘛
Jake: What does he do when he's mad?
Jake:会不吃饭
Jake: He won't eat.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Alice: 反正会被会把自己气死啊
Alice: Anyway, he'll just get so mad at himself.
Jake:会啊就是不吃饭估计
Jake: Yeah, like he won't eat, I guess.
Lucia: 我好想养
Lucia: I really want to keep one.
Lucia: 我喜欢这种比较粘人的动物
Lucia: I like clingy animals.
Alice: 暹罗猫嘛
Alice: A Siamese cat?
Alice: 暹罗猫像狗一样的
Alice: Siamese cats are like dogs.
Jake:他认识
Jake: He knows.
Jake:他认识你是吧
Jake: He knows you, right?
Jake:他他会认识人
Jake: He knows people.
Jake:他认人蜘蛛认人吗
Jake: Does a spider know people?
Jake:蜘蛛应该没这脑子吧
Jake: A spider probably doesn't have that kind of brain.
Jake:总共那么大一点
Jake: It's only this big.
Jake:你指望他多大脑袋啊
Jake: How big a brain do you expect it to have?
Jake:对这个哺乳动物都不是
Jake: It's not even a mammal.
Lucia: 蛇也不怎么认了
Lucia: Snakes don't really recognize people either.
Alice: 蛇不咬人就很粘人
Alice: Snakes are very clingy if they don't bite.
Jake:对就很粘人
Jake: Yeah, very clingy.
Jake:我就喜欢这种粘人小动物
Jake: I like clingy pets.
Jake:对小狗
Jake: Like dogs.
Lucia: 但是但是
Lucia: But, but...
Lucia: 把家里弄得很乱
Lucia: They make the house so messy.
Lucia: 所以我就不能养这种什么猫啊狗啊
Lucia: So I can't keep cats or dogs.
Lucia: 这个散了
Lucia: It's a hassle.
Lucia: 虽然我很想养
Lucia: Even though I really want to.
Lucia: 居然有他大吗
Lucia: Is it as big as him?
Alice: 不大不大
Alice: Not that big.
Lucia: 哦哎那还可以
Lucia: Oh, okay, that's fine then.
Tasha: 你们在脑电波交流吗
Tasha: Are you guys communicating telepathically?
Jake:我看他这个灯关了
Jake: I saw his light went out.
Alice: 我灯还亮着呢
Alice: My light's still on.
Jake:啊你这灯
Jake: Ah, your light.
Jake:但他其实是这个头发挡住了
Jake: But actually, his hair was covering it.
Jake:所以我刚刚让他撩一下
Jake: So I just told him to move it aside.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahaha
Jake:喝咖啡吧
Jake: Let's have some coffee.
Lucia: 你应该这样
Lucia: You should do it like this.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈我去
Jake: Hahaha, oh my god.
Jake:刚刚这波数据挺离谱的
Jake: That last data was quite absurd.
Jake:你上面招呼招呼我就出现了
Jake: When you called for me, I just appeared.
Jake:是的嗯
Jake: Yeah, right.
Jake:哈哈哈来看一眼你出现
Jake: Haha, take a look at your appearance.
Jake:杨老板要尝试一下吗
Jake: Do you want to give it a try?
Jake:好啊
Jake: Sure.
Shure:  再泡杯咖啡
Shure: Brew another cup of coffee.
Jake:好泡一泡
Jake: Sure, let's brew one.
Jake:这么专业必须
Jake: So professional, we must.
Shure: 分毫不差哈哈
Shure: Not a single cent off, haha.
Jake:这一杯卖多少钱
Jake: How much does this cup sell for?
Shure:  这一杯你要因为你要去咖啡店
Shure: This cup would be, since you're going to a coffee shop.
Jake:五六十起
Jake: Fifty or sixty at least.
Jake:就是死啊
Jake: That's just crazy.
Jake:不是国内的实心币
Jake: Not local currency.
Jake:国内的五六十
Jake: Fifty or sixty locally.
Jake:国内五六十搁新加坡就得20多
Jake: Fifty or sixty locally, in Singapore it's over twenty.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  那不是这个
Shure: That's not it.
Jake:十几啊
Jake: Ten something then.
Shure:  好像全球都一个价
Shure: Seems like it's the same price globally.
Jake:那就实心比
Jake: Then it's real price.
Jake:那也差不多吧
Jake: That should be about right.
Jake:15克的豆子
Jake: 15 grams of beans.
Jake:然后我们这次就每次我跟你讲
Jake: Then every time we do this, I tell you.
Shure:  就每次我给你讲一般手冲的话他们会跟你讲一下
Shure: Each time I tell you, usually for hand-brewed, they will tell you.
Jake:会给你讲看
Jake: They will tell you, see.
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: 这是一个什么圭下的一个日晒的豆子
Shure: This is a sun-dried bean from some region.
Shure: 然后它是一个浅度烘焙的
Shure: And it's lightly roasted.
Shure: 然后风味概述主要有以下这些
Shure: The flavor profile mainly includes these.
Jake:就是他建议你做这玩意是吧
Jake: So they suggest you make this, right?
Shure: 不是能尝试有这些味道哦
Shure: No, you can try to taste these flavors.
Jake:那蜂柚子茶他是怎么给弄进去的呢
Jake: How do they get the honey pomelo tea flavor in there?
Jake:它的味道怎么弄进去哦
Jake: How do you get the flavor in?
Jake:然后就用一个这个形容词形容一下
Jake: Then just use an adjective to describe it.
Jake:这么回事哦
Jake: That's how it works.
Jake:多少克 15克
Jake: How many grams? 15 grams?
Shure:  哎呦卧槽
Shure: Oh my gosh.
Jake:怎么办
Jake: What to do?
Shure:  往回倒哈哈哈哈
Shure: Pour it back, haha.
Shure: 失误了完了
Shure: I made a mistake, it's over.
Shure: 杨老板一看我
Shure: Jake is looking at me.
Shure:  我整不会了
Shure: I can't do this.
Shure: 尝试操作一下
Shure: Try to operate it.
Jake:哇这么带劲
Jake: Wow, this is intense.
Jake:开过拖拉机吗
Jake: Have you ever driven a tractor?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  会手摇拖拉机
Shure: I can hand-crank a tractor.
Shure:  拖拉机打火时候就摇头摇
Shure: When starting a tractor, you crank it.
Jake:哎这是这算摇完了吗
Jake: Hey, is this cranking done?
Shure:  对这就摇完了
Shure: Yes, it's done.
Shure:  嗯下一步
Shure: Okay, next step.
Shure: 这个长条的凹凸
Shure: This long strip, bumpy part.
Jake:为啥要auto
Jake: Why auto?
Shure: 嗯就是它可以自动吸食
Shure: Well, it can automatically absorb.
Shure:  方便一点
Shure: It's more convenient.
Jake:嗯那砌石了吗
Jake: Hmm, has the stone been laid?
Shure: 还没有呢
Shure: Not yet.
Shure: 一会注水才开始砌石哦
Shure: We'll start laying the stone after adding water.
Shure:  滤纸就是把咖啡渣滤出去哦
Shure: The filter paper is used to filter out the coffee grounds.
Jake:他们谁说用咖啡渣做什么东西的
Jake: Someone said they used coffee grounds for something.
Jake:什么啊对
Jake: What was it?
Shure: 记着吗其实可以当肥料
Shure: Remember? It can be used as fertilizer.
Jake:什么他们
Jake: What?
Jake:他们好像说
Jake: They said...
Jake:咖啡渣做做装饰品
Jake: Coffee grounds can be used to make decorations.
Jake:什么玩意
Jake: What the heck.
Jake:前几天说
Jake: They said that a few days ago.
Jake:的
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:这92度你是咋知道的
Jake: How do you know it's 92 degrees?
Jake:哈哈官方建议
Jake: Haha, official recommendation.
Shure:  你真的就跟我答答辩
Shure: You really sound like you're defending a thesis.
Shure:  老师你这个是怎么知道
Shure: Teacher, how did you know this?
Shure:  我说百度百度搜的
Shure: I said I searched it on Baidu.
Shure:  让让我这么做的对
Shure: They told me to do it this way, right.
Jake:哈为啥
Jake: Huh, why?
Jake:用这个参数是吧对
Jake: Using this parameter, right?
Shure: 你就可以拿着
Shure: You can take it.
Shure: 然后开始操作
Shure: Then start operating.
Shure:  来吧好
Shure: Come on, alright.
Shure: 尝试一下
Shure: Give it a try.
Jake:倒多少
Jake: How much to pour?
Shure:  倒到大概用50克左右
Shure: Pour about 50 grams or so.
Jake:先转转一圈
Jake: First, spin it around once.
Katrina:  但这个好拆
Katrina: But this is easy to dismantle.
Shure: OK收完了
Shure: OK, done.
Shure: 好 50克左右没事
Shure: Okay, 50 grams or so, it's fine.
Shure:  没事
Shure: It's fine.
Jake:多了没事
Jake: It's okay if it's a bit more.
Shure:  第一步一步叫做分蒸
Shure: The first step is called "fen zheng".
Jake:闷蒸
Jake: "Men zheng".
Shure: 就是让他这个气体稍微排出来一点
Shure: It means letting the gas out a little bit.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 然后大概闷蒸30秒收拾房间
Shure: Then let it steam for about 30 seconds to prep the room.
Shure: 就把他的这个香味先激发出来
Shure: This brings out its aroma first.
Jake:好能闻到吗能闻到
Jake: Okay, can you smell it? Yes, you can smell it.
Shure: 然后之后继续继续转多少
Shure: After that, keep spinning it around.
Shure: 慢慢的一圈一圈
Shure: Slowly, one circle at a time.
Shure: 然后最后到了240
Shure: Eventually reaching 240.
Shure: 慢慢的再慢点一圈一圈
Shure: Slowly, a bit slower, one circle at a time.
Jake:你从哪学的这玩意
Jake: Where did you learn this stuff?
Shure: 买了本书
Shure: Bought a book.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh my god.
Jake:然后那那器具你是也是根据书买的
Jake: And the equipment, did you buy it based on the book too?
Shure: 也不是呃
Shure: Not really, uh...
Shure: 这就是找一些视频然后看推荐什么的
Shure: Just watched some videos and saw recommendations.
Shure: 哦再稍微快一点也可以
Shure: Oh, a bit faster is also fine.
Jake:他不能有泡吗还是不讲究
Jake: Should it have bubbles or not?
Shure:  嗯没那么讲究 240对
Shure: Hmm, not that particular, 240 is good.
Shure: 他这个冲煮方式有很多
Shure: There are many ways to brew it.
Shure: 嗯刚刚那种就叫一刀流就是哦
Shure: Hmm, just now was called "one-cut flow", which is...
Shure: 焖蒸之后然后一直倒一直倒一直倒
Shure: After steaming, keep pouring continuously.
Jake:倒到嗯嗯嗯还有很多分批
Jake: Pouring, uh-huh, there are many steps.
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh
Shure: 三段式几段法这种都有什么差别吗
Shure: What's the difference between the three-stage method and other methods?
Jake:这种都有什么差别吗
Shure: 它确实会不一样
Shure: They are indeed different.
Shure: 但你究竟哪种好喝这也说不出来
Shure: But which one tastes better, I can't really say.
Jake:确实它肯定是是能
Jake: Indeed, it definitely can...
Shure:  他肯定是是能对
Shure: It definitely can, right.
Jake:对但是这个的优势就是它快就好
Jake: Right, but the advantage of this one is that it's quick.
Jake:这个优势明显
Jake: This advantage is obvious.
Jake:明显
Jake: Obvious.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:大哥先喝
Jake: Big brother, you drink first.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake:刚刚拆了3个
Jake: Just opened three.
Jake:看来要补点杯子
Jake: Seems like we need to get more cups.
Shure:  咱们给他补了个水壶了
Shure: We got him a kettle.
Jake:呵呵呵cheers
Jake: Hehehe, cheers.
Jake:他这个还是往下流吗
Jake: Is it still flowing down?
Jake:还是还在往下流哦
Jake: It's still flowing down, huh.
Jake:一块擦掉是吧
Jake: Wipe it off, right?
Shure: 对谢谢你
Shure: Yeah, thank you.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:这个要配点奶
Jake: This needs some milk.
Jake:配吗一般一般不配
Jake: Does it? Usually, we don't add milk.
Shure: 一般一般不配
Shure: Usually, we don't add milk.
Jake:那就硬喝这个哦行
Jake: Then I'll just drink it straight, alright.
Jake:嚯这么重
Jake: Whoa, so heavy.
Shure:  猜猜这个小东西
Shure: Guess this little thing.
Jake:嗯这个你看我可猜不出来几百
Jake: Hmm, I can't guess, maybe a few hundred.
Shure: 300块
Shure: 300 bucks.
Jake: 300块就这个
Jake: 300 bucks for this?
Shure: 哦这个东西还往上还有贵
Shure: Yeah, and there are even more expensive ones.
Shure: 就是什么里面的刀头会怎么怎么样
Shure: It's like, the blade inside does something specific.
Jake:更好切吗
Jake: Cuts better?
Jake:还是切的更碎更均匀
Jake: Or cuts finer and more evenly.
Shure: 更均匀就是保证每个颗粒的大小几
Shure: More evenly, ensuring each grain is almost the same size.
Shure: 乎是一样
Shure: Almost the same.
Jake:傻屌吧哈哈
Jake: Silly, right? Haha.
Jake:确实讲究
Jake: It's really particular.
Jake:但是就是那种大机器
Jake: But it's that kind of big machine.
Shure: 大机器也也有讲究
Shure: Even big machines have their specifics.
Jake:就是那个大机器
Jake: It's that big machine.
Jake:他应该做的更均匀是吧
Jake: It should make it more even, right?
Jake:哦哦还有那种带电的
Jake: Oh, oh, there's also the kind that's electric.
Jake:带电自己切
Jake: It cuts by itself when it's electric.
Jake:哈哈没关系
Jake: Haha, it's okay.
Jake:这
Jake: This...
Jake:是一个弯吗
Jake: Is it a curve?
Shure:  嗯差不多
Shure: Hmm, close enough.
Jake:差不多差在哪
Jake: What's the difference?
Shure: 差在这两个点
Shure: The difference is in these two points.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈可以
Jake: Hahahaha, okay.
Jake:完了感觉纯大变是很像啊
Jake: Well, it feels like the pure change is very similar.
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Jake:呵呵做plantation
Jake: Haha, making plantations.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Shure:  对对对
Shure: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake:QA环节
Jake: QA session.
Jake:这个和是差哪儿了
Jake: What's the difference between this and that?
Shure:  对而且安迪他说话有
Shure: Yeah, and Andy, he has an accent.
Shure:  容易很多有口音他那个why
Shure: It's easier for him to say "why."
Shure: w是why why嘛他
Shure: "W" is "why." Why, why, he...
Shure: why why why why
Shure: Why, why, why, why.
Jake:哎呀快递饺子来了
Jake: Ah, the dumplings delivery has arrived.
Jake:应该我端下去喝你好
Jake: I should take them downstairs and say hello.
Jake:哎好
Jake: Oh, okay.
Jake:来了稍等啊来了哎
Jake: Coming, hold on, coming, hey.
Jake:吃饺子
Jake: Eat dumplings.
Alice: 这是
Alice: This is...
Jake:送给大家
Jake: For everyone.
Alice: 这是鸟身上长了个柳树吗
Alice: Is this a bird with a willow tree growing on it?
Alice: 是吗
Alice: Is it?
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Ah.
Jake:咱也不懂啊
Jake: We don't understand either.
Jake:咱也不是住这了
Jake: We don't live here.
Jake:是是这意思是吧
Jake: Is that what it means?
Jake:对咱也不知道是这么个地方
Jake: Yeah, we didn't know it's this kind of place.
Jake:我也找半天了
Jake: I've been looking for a while too.
Jake:拜拜谢谢你
Jake: Bye, thank you.
Jake:哎好谢谢
Jake: Oh, thanks.
Jake:吃饺子
Jake: Eat dumplings.
Jake:哦谢谢
Jake: Oh, thanks.
其他人：这些都不用动
Others: Don't touch these.
其他人：你们的是吧
Others: These are yours, right?
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh...
Jake:用不用了
Jake: Do we need them?
Jake:路亚你觉得要动吗
Jake: Nicous, do you think we need to move these?
Jake:这些箱子可能还得用吧
Jake: We might still need these boxes.
Jake:你们留着吧
Jake: You guys keep them.
Jake:我们都留着
Jake: We'll keep them all.
Jake:行我们都留着吧
Jake: Okay, we'll keep them all.
Lucia: 也不用都我看一眼
Lucia: Not all of them, let me check.
Alice: 卢亚那个泡沫箱能帮我拆一下吗
Alice: Nicous, can you help me take apart that foam box?
Alice: 好像也有
Alice: I think there's something inside.
Alice: 对
Alice: Yes.
Alice: 然后把那个蛋挞皮放到冰箱里冷冻
Alice: And put the tart shells in the freezer.
Alice: 因为我怕他再不冷冻他会不会化掉
Alice: Because I'm afraid if we don't freeze them, they'll melt.
Jake:谢谢您
Jake: Thank you.
Lucia: 这好像还没拆
Lucia: This hasn't been opened yet.
Lucia: 是谁的呀
Lucia: Whose is it?
Lucia: 粉色加吉
Lucia: Pink and urgent.
Jake:还加了个急对
Jake: It even says urgent, right.
Jake:这这没拆
Jake: This hasn't been opened.
Katrina:  哈哈哈直接把人解释蒙了
Katrina: Haha, it completely confused the person.
Katrina:  那个打歌服的预算是
Katrina: What's the budget for the performance outfits?
Jake:一般是多少啊
Jake: Usually how much?
Jake:我不太懂这个东西
Jake: I don't really know about this stuff.
Katrina:  刚刚那个谁微微看的是一百多一套
Katrina: Just now, Tasha saw that each set is around 100+.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Katrina:  100多一套的六套的话那100多 100
Katrina: 100+ per set, so for six sets, that's 100...
Jake:100多那就是就是6就是1,000就是六六百
Jake: 100+, so that means 6 is 1,000, or 600.
Katrina:  多那就是1,000
Katrina: More like 1,000.
Jake:600多什么样的
Jake: What does 600+ look like?
Jake:600多有点
Jake: 600+ is a bit...
Jake:他挑的是粉色跟黑色系列
Jake: They chose pink and black series.
Jake:我我求求去
Jake: I'll go check it out.
Jake:我瞧瞧去来瞧
Jake: I'll take a look, let's check.
Katrina:  哎他在这
Katrina: Hey, he's here.
Jake:一瞧你们的衣服
Jake: Look at your clothes.
Jake:我勒个去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Tasha: 这只是其中一套
Tasha: This is just one set.
Tasha: 这是第二套
Tasha: This is the second set.
Tasha: 这是第三套
Tasha: This is the third set.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice: 这怎么是一整个
Alice: How is this a whole set?
Katrina:  就是哇哇哇
Katrina: It's like wow, wow, wow.
Tasha: 这是第四套
Tasha: This is the fourth set.
Tasha: 第五套这是修硕的
Tasha: The fifth set is Shure's.
Tasha: 你看我给他找了个男款
Tasha: Look, I found him a men's version.
Tasha: 这是第六套
Tasha: This is the sixth set.
Tasha: 嗯你觉得哪套好看
Tasha: So, which one do you think looks the best?
Jake:都好看
Jake: They all look good.
Jake:我想想啊
Jake: Let me think.
Alice: 这是个完整的
Alice: This is a complete one.
Lucia: 这是啥情况
Lucia: What's going on here?
Alice: 这吧我可以看一下这个吗
Alice: Can I take a look at this one?
Katrina:  可以这是我觉得眼神不好
Katrina: Sure, I think my eyesight is poor.
Jake:可
Jake: Sure.
Katrina:  土里面长了两个
Katrina: Two of them grew in the soil.
Katrina:  还能
Katrina: It can still...
Katrina:  这个然后还有就是
Katrina: This one and also...
Katrina:  那个可以弄在那个亚克力板里面
Katrina: That one can be put into the acrylic board.
Katrina:  应该会挺好看
Katrina: It should look pretty good.
Katrina:  我想要不要压一点
Katrina: I wonder if I should press it a bit.
Katrina:  你要压吗
Katrina: Do you want to press it?
Jake:以
Jake: Eh...
Katrina:  现在还有
Katrina: There's still...
Katrina:  你可以把你那个盛开的就压一下
Katrina: You can press the blooming ones.
Katrina:  随便弄两个就行
Katrina: Just press a couple randomly.
Katrina:  我这有有几个板
Katrina: I have some boards here.
Katrina:  皮克皮克
Katrina: Peek, peek.
Katrina:  其实特简单
Katrina: It's actually very simple.
Katrina:  就是把它一层层叠起来
Katrina: Just stack them layer by layer.
Katrina:  然后铺在上面
Katrina: Then spread them out.
Katrina:  然后把它绑住就可以
Katrina: And tie them up, that's it.
Jake:这玩意有租的吗
Jake: Can you rent this thing?
Jake:什么这玩意有租的吗
Jake:啊这玩意有租的吗
Jake: Ah, is this thing available for rent?
Tasha: 租的不知道
Tasha: Not sure if it's for rent.
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:或者这玩意这玩意能退吗
Jake: Or can this thing be returned?
Jake:哎或者这玩意能二手吗
Jake: Or can this thing be bought second-hand?
Jake:或者这玩意能干掉吗
Jake: Or can this thing be gotten rid of?
Tasha: 干掉
Tasha: Gotten rid of?
Jake:就是就是
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Tasha: 什么意思
Tasha: What do you mean?
Jake:省点钱对呵呵呵
Jake: To save some money, right? Haha.
Alice: 超预算了
Alice: Over budget.
Alice: 那要不统一买50块钱一套的
Alice: How about we all buy the $50 set?
Jake:不是就看你问问他
Jake: No, just ask him.
Jake:你问问他这个
Jake: Ask him about this.
Jake:便宜点或者你看能不能退掉
Jake: See if we can get it cheaper or return it.
Jake:二手还是能不能借租
Jake: Second-hand or renting it?
Alice: 或者搜一下附近有没有什么拍照的
Alice: Or search nearby if there's a photography studio.
Alice: 什么写真馆的
Alice: Like a portrait studio.
Alice: 他们那种礼服
Alice: They have those outfits.
Jake:这种也行
Jake: That works too.
Jake:对 100块钱我都租台电脑
Jake: Yeah, I can rent a computer for $100.
Jake:我再拿二二代电脑
Jake: And get another Gen 2 computer.
Tasha: 或者这个就全部都买这一款
Tasha: Or we could just buy all of this model.
Tasha: 这一款才40块钱一套
Tasha: This model is only $40 a set.
Jake:OK就看我们看有没有别的渠道吧
Jake: OK, let's see if we have other options.
Jake:就是除了买的话
Jake: Besides buying.
Jake:因为
Jake: Because...
Alice: 你可以配黑裤子也可以男生
Alice: You can pair it with black pants too, for guys.
Jake:对对因为买的话好像没啥必要
Jake: Yeah, yeah, because buying seems unnecessary.
Jake:你问能不能退
Jake: Ask if we can return it.
Jake:或者就是
Jake: Or...
Jake:或者就是他
Jake: Or maybe...
Jake:他这个商家也没有什么租的服务
Jake: Does this vendor offer rental services?
Jake:是这个你说我们就要6套吗
Jake: We just need six sets, right?
Jake:是你这是一家店啊
Jake: Is this a single store?
Jake:不同的店哈说的
Jake: Or are these different stores?
Alice: 为什么我觉得这个屋子比别的要热
Alice: Why do I feel this room is hotter than the others?
Alice: 是因为电脑多吗
Alice: Is it because of the computers?
Alice: 这个灯像一个苹果
Alice: This lamp looks like an apple.
Alice: 还有那个花边边
Alice: And that lace trim
Tasha: 哦还真有租的
Tasha: Oh, you can actually rent it
Jake:嗯那只能租这种
Jake: Yeah, you can only rent this kind
Jake:我靠好看
Jake: Wow, it looks good
Alice: 我看
Alice: Let me see
Jake:这多少钱
Jake: How much is this?
Tasha: 45一套那为什么不买一套呢
Tasha: 45 per set, why not just buy a set?
Tasha: 买一套不在40吗
Tasha: Isn't it 40 to buy a set?
Jake:确实所以这是什么
Jake: True, so what is this?
Jake:一件40 组令
Jake: One piece is 40, to rent
Jake:对啊组多久
Jake: Right, how long can you rent it?
Jake:组多久不知道哎
Jake: How long can you rent it? No idea
Jake:那这个是很厉害的服装吗
Jake: Is this a really good outfit?
Jake:这得1,000或者好几百
Jake: This must be 1,000 or several hundred
Jake:市场都是女的
Jake: The market is all women
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah
Tasha: 他这边写真馆租租衣服的也比较多
Tasha: There are many photo studios renting out clothes here too
Tasha: 40块钱三一天
Tasha: 40 bucks for three days
Alice:一天是一般多少钱一天
Alice: How much is it usually for one day?
Jake:一天30 那我要买一套40
Jake: 30 a day, so I'd rather buy a set for 40
Jake:买一套40
Jake: Buy a set for 40
Jake:可以啊可以
Jake: Yeah, that works
Alice: 就只能买最便宜的那个
Alice: But you can only buy the cheapest one
Alice: 小咖了
Alice: That's too cheap
Jake:对
Jake: Right
Jake:这个意思就是不是那么重要这个东西
Jake: It means this thing isn't that important
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Alice: 可以点歌吗
Alice: Can we request songs?
Katrina:  蝴蝶我也想听蝴蝶
Katrina: Butterfly, I want to hear Butterfly
Katrina:  再压一层
Katrina: Layer it again
Jake:蝴蝶你们跳
Jake: You guys dance to Butterfly
Katrina:  那肯定是我还没有决定
Katrina: Of course, but I haven't decided yet
Katrina:  好陶喆
Katrina: Alright, David Tao
Jake:这是你的桌子
Jake: This is your table
Jake:这是什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Jake:是桌子桌子怎么长成这样
Jake: It's a table, why does it look like this?
Katrina:  这是收纳箱哎
Katrina: This is a storage box
Lucia: 不是他拼起来
Lucia: No, he assembled it
Katrina:  我到时候买这些装饰房间东西
Katrina: When I buy these decorations for the room
Katrina:  我就不带回去
Katrina: I won't take them back
Jake:哦OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Katrina:  我直接给你寄过来
Katrina: I'll just send it to you directly.
Alice: 这是一个不太小的工作量耶
Alice: This is quite a lot of work.
Tasha: 我来帮你吧
Tasha: I'll help you.
Katrina:  到时候直接放我房间就行
Katrina: Just put it in my room when it arrives.
Katrina:  买那种香薰还有地毯还有挂画
Katrina: Buy some aromatherapy stuff, a carpet, and some wall art.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Katrina:  还有娃娃
Katrina: And some dolls.
Lucia: 就是他带一个抽屉
Lucia: It comes with a drawer.
Lucia: 所以他会边上要
Lucia: So, it needs to have space on the side.
Jake:走吧吃饺子去
Jake: Let's go eat dumplings.
Katrina:  去二楼吃饺子吗
Katrina: Are we eating dumplings on the second floor?
Jake:二楼吃饺子
Jake: Dumplings on the second floor.
Tasha: 到了吗
Tasha: Are we there yet?
Jake:对音箱也可以弄上去
Jake: Yeah, we can set up the speakers too.
Alice: 我们吃饭的时候需要录吗呃
Alice: Do we need to record while we're eating?
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh...
Jake:吃饭录着吧
Jake: Let's record while eating.
Jake:空心镯子是吧
Jake: A hollow bracelet, right?
Jake:它是一个它
Jake: It's a...
Jake:这个上面有没有
Jake: Does it...
Jake:有没有呈现完整的效
Jake: Does it show the complete effect?
Lucia: 那最后是一个这样的一个小东西
Lucia: So, in the end, it's this little thing.
Jake:哦哦哦那这个就合理了起来
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, that makes sense now.
Alice: 让我看看
Alice: Let me see.
Jake:突然make sense
Jake: Suddenly makes sense.
Tasha: 那培养皿得好等会
Tasha: What about the petri dish?
Tasha: 培养皿买了吗
Tasha: Did you buy the petri dish?
Jake:买了
Jake: Yes, I did.
Tasha: 在哪
Tasha: Where is it?
Jake:不知道不种
Jake: I don't know, not planting it?
Tasha: 还不种
Tasha: Not planting it yet?
Jake:不知道不种状不就来不及了
Jake: If we don't plant it, we won't make it in time.
Alice:不种状不就来不及了
Alice: If we don't plant it, we won't make it in time.
Jake:种什么时候种
Jake: When should we plant it?
Jake:呃看到什么
Jake: Uh, what do we see?
Jake:看到倒没倒
Jake: See if it falls or not.
Jake:还有别的喝吗
Jake: Anything else to drink?
Jake:可能是这个吧
Jake: Maybe it's this one.
Katrina:  这个这有个快递
Katrina: There's a package here.
Katrina:  是那个杨笑脸谁的
Katrina: Is that Yang's smiley face?
Jake:笑脸
Jake: Smiley face.
Katrina:  我给你我直接写的杨靖康
Katrina: I wrote it directly as Yang Jingkang.
Katrina:  那应该不是我买的
Katrina: So it shouldn't be mine.
Katrina:  杨笑脸
Katrina: Yang's smiley face.
Jake:笑脸interesting
Jake: Smiley face, interesting.
Katrina:  是你买的吗
Katrina: Did you buy it?
Jake:我不知道我看一下
Jake: I don't know, let me check.
Jake:这什么呀这什么呀
Jake: What's this? What's this?
Jake:蝴蝶风铃
Jake: Butterfly wind chime.
Lucia: 我的
Lucia: It's mine.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Katrina:  这是我材料包
Katrina: This is my materials pack.
Katrina:  今天又做手工了
Katrina: Doing crafts again today.
Katrina:  昨天化妆今天不想化妆
Katrina: Did makeup yesterday, don't feel like doing it today.
Katrina:  你在追什么剧啊
Katrina: What show are you watching?
Jake:这是货币是吧
Jake: This is money, right?
Jake:嗯嗯中央银行哈哈哈
Jake: Yeah, yeah, central bank, haha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈150个差不多吧
Katrina: Haha, about 150 should be fine.
Jake:可以挺好
Jake: That's good, pretty good.
Jake:大银行
Jake: Big bank.
Lucia: 哦我明白了这好像也不是那么难搞
Lucia: Oh, I get it, it doesn't seem that hard to handle.
Jake:呵
Jake: Heh.
Jake:挺好你这说明书对应的挺好哈哈哈
Jake: Pretty good, your instruction manual matches quite well, haha.
Tasha: 通州区演出服装租赁
Tasha: Tongzhou District performance costume rental.
Jake:这个好甚至我们可以去挑
Jake: This is good, we could even go pick.
Jake:嗯如果不远的话
Jake: Yeah, if it's not too far.
Jake:我们
Jake: We...
Jake:不远的话下午我们打个车去挑衣服
Jake: If it's not far, we can take a cab to pick clothes in the afternoon.
Jake:都可以
Jake: All good.
Alice: 为什么不能打个车去买衣服
Alice: Why can't we take a cab to buy clothes?
Alice: 哈哈哈没关系我只是随便说说
Alice: Haha, never mind, I'm just saying.
Jake:因为
Jake: Because...
Jake:到到时候算算算一算
Jake: We can calculate it at the time.
Jake:因为这看这打车费加上这多少钱
Jake: Because, see, the cab fare plus how much this costs.
Jake:打折费应该到不了1,000
Jake: The discount fee shouldn't be over 1,000.
Tasha: 人员的一项工作
Tasha: A task for the personnel.
Jake:呃人员的一项工作
Jake: Uh, a task for the personnel.